أريد أن أستغل الثواني القليلة الماضية السيد
المتحدث لإعطاء بعض النصائح
لأه وخليفي مهما كان هو أو
هي رقم واحد ، ابق على مقربة من
الأمريكيين التمسك بالأوكرانيين
التمسك بالحرية والديمقراطية في
كل مكان وخفض الضرائب وإلغاء الضوابط.
أينما استطعت لجعل هذا
أفضل مكان للعيش والاستثمار
فيه ،
فأنا أحب الخزانة ولكن تذكر
أنه إذا استمعنا دائمًا إلى
الخزانة ، فلن نبني M25
أو نفق القناة
للتركيز على الطريق أمامنا
ركز على الطريق أمامك ولكن
تذكر دائمًا التحقق من مرآة الرؤية الخلفية
وتذكر قبل كل شيء أنه ليس تويتر
هو المهم هو الأشخاص الذين أرسلونا إلى
هنا ونعم سيدي كانت السنوات القليلة
الماضية أعظم امتياز في حياتي
وهذا صحيح  أنني ساعدت في الحصول على
أكبر أغلبية من المحافظين لمدة 40 عامًا
وإعادة تنظيم كبير في السياسة البريطانية السيد
المتحدث ، لقد غيرنا
ديمقراطيتنا واستعدنا استقلالنا الوطني
كما قال صديقي العادي
"  لقد ساعدت في
اجتياز هذا البلد للوباء والمساعدة في إنقاذ
بلد آخر من البربرية
وبصراحة هذا يكفي لمواصلة
المهمة التي أنجزت إلى حد كبير
في الوقت
الحالي أريد أن أشكرك السيد المتحدث وأود أن
أشكر جميع الموظفين الرائعين في
بيت المشاع ، أريد أن أشكر جميع
أصدقائي وزملائي ،
سأشكر صديقي الملكي ، آه ، السيد المتحدث المقابل ،
أريد أن أشكر كل شخص
أجنبي ،
شكرًا لك حبيبي